John F.
Kennedy served as the 35th president of the United States before he was killed
in 1963 while we all know about JFK,
chances are that you probably know more about the conspiracy theory surrounding
his assassination then the actual details of his life.
This story goes far deeper than just the individual life of John F.
Kennedy.
In order to understand the man you need to know the family and how he was far
from the only one whose life ended in tragedy.
On today's biographics,
we will discuss the real man who was behind the presidency.
The Kennedys have been called American royalty and to the outside world.
They were a symbol of the American dream.
It all started when Patrick Kennedy married Bridget Murphy,
who emigrated from Ireland to the United States in the 18 hundreds Patrick died
at an early age leaving Bridget,
a widow and a single mother.
She became a full time maid for a wealthy family in Boston.
After a few years,
though,
Bridget Kennedy managed to save her money and opens up in general store.
Her only son,
Patrick Junior,
was called PJ and at 14 years old he started working in the general store with
his mother.
When he was in his twenties PJ opens an Irish pub.
He made so much money that he purchased a bar in an upscale hotel as well as the
local bank,
Bj's son,
Joseph P.
Kennedy would be the first to grow up enjoying the fruits of his ancestors
labor.
He went to Harvard University where he got a taste of high society.
Unfortunately though,
Joseph was snubbed by a lot of his classmates and denied from answering several
fatalities.
While it's hard to imagine now,
there was actually a huge stigma against Irish Catholics back then,
especially among the American elite.
Most of the upper class American families were descended from British
Protestants who taught their children that the Irish were low class,
good for nothing.
Drugs this stereotype,
it motivated Joseph Kennedy to become a millionaire and prove everybody wrong.
Joseph Kennedy married the Mayor of Boston's daughter,
Rose Fitzgerald.
They went on to have nine children together.
The oldest son was named a juicy of junior runs.
Even as an infant.
His parents would say that he would grow up to be the presidents of the United
States.
His second son,
John Fitzgerald Kennedy was born on May the 29th of 1917 but everyone called him
Jack Rose.
We'd go on to have seven more children and they all grew up watching their
father work hard to make his first million before the age of 35 in the 1920s
Joseph Kennedy was hustling to make as much money as he could by any means
necessary.
You took advantage of prohibition by buying of the alcohol just before the laws
were scheduled to change.
He ran speakeasies with a man named Sam g and Connor,
who was connected to the Chicago mob.
He also played the stock markets and made millions running schemes that would
now be considered rather illegal.
Before long,
Joseph Kennedy became the richest Irish Catholic in the United States.
Since he was always trying to climb the ladder for more money and more power
dress of Kennedy began to get involved in politics.
President.
Franklin Delano Roosevelt was impressed when Kennedy's Wyss and charisma,
and so it was appointed as the ambassador to Great Britain considering that he
had spent his entire life trying to prove that Irish men could be just as
successful as the English.
This was the cherry on top of Kennedy's achievements and the only way it could
get any better was if one of his sons became the president
and Andy was an adorable baby with big blue eyes.
But even during his earliest days in life,
he was already very sick.
By the age of three,
he had had whooping cough,
chicken pox or measles and scarlet fever.
Jack was also diagnosed with a condition called Addison's disease.
Indeed,
because of all of this,
you spent a lot of his young life living in the hospital.
His parents,
they were told by doctors that he may not survive to adult it.
However,
Jack was a very happy kid since he handled a lot of love for life.
Friends and relatives say that he never complained about his illnesses and that
he was always smiling and always making checks.
His siblings made light of his condition.
Joking that if a mosquito bit him,
he would die instantly.
The good of the children,
they grew up meeting members of the British aristocracy from a young age,
so they were taught traditional attic cabs.
They became this uniquely all American family who had the charm of British
royalty while most of the children were living with their father in London.
Both Jack and his older brother Joe Jr attended a private high school called
Choate,
Rosemary Hall in Connecticut.
Joe Junior was the most popular guy in school and the all around the golden boy.
He was a varsity football player who was good looking,
outgoing and charismatic and got straight A's.
Jack,
on the other hand,
was the polar opposite of his older brother because of his disease.
He grew up feeling as if every day might be as lost,
so he was constantly living life to the fullest.
He got cs in every subject except English and history,
just like his father.
Jack got some backlash from his peers for being Irish.
Some of the other kids called him market because that was the nickname given to
Irish man who would clean up the horse manure in the stables and English navels
instead of sulking.
Jack countered the bullies by embracing the name is even proudly wore a necklace
with a gold shovel.
Chogm.
He created a group on campus called the market's club and they dedicated their
free time to playing crazy pranks around campus.
Soon enough being a marker.
It wasn't a derogatory term anymore.
It was a badge of honor.
Some of the most popular boys in the school joined his clubs so that they could
raise hell.
If Youtube had existed back then,
there is no doubt that they would be filming these pranks and putting them on
the platform.
In fact,
Kennedy was planning a prank where they'd bring in a huge amount of manure ends
in the middle of the school's dance floor and take photographs of the students
and teachers reactions when they opened the doors.
When the Dean caught wind of this plan,
he called in Joseph Kennedy for a parent teacher conference.
Jack was nearly kicked out of school,
but his father stepped in and prevented him from being expelled with a wink and
a smile.
Jason Senior was teaching Jack that he didn't have to play by the rules that
normal people played by the Kennedy's.
They were always able to pay someone off.
Unfortunately,
Jack's recklessness,
it would catch up to him when he became seriously injured during a football
game.
He ruptured a disc in his back and it took months of surgeries and time in the
hospital before he could even walk again.
He never fully recovered and to be in pain for the rest of his life.
After graduating from high school,
Jaquinta Harvard bound side of pass see joins the swimming and sailing teams and
was known for being a ladies' man.
Even though he had a passion for English literature,
his father pushed him to study political science and law.
He also arranged for him and his older brother,
Joe Junior to get summer jobs in the American embassy in London.
Jack and his father.
They would send letters back and forth about politics and when World War Two
began,
he already had plenty of insight and knowledge about what was going on in
Europe.
For his senior thesis,
Jack wrote a book called why England slabs,
which basically reiterated his father's beliefs about how he believed Great
Britain was not prepared for World War II.
It became a best seller in,
did establish the name John F.
Kennedy as a political expert at an early age.
While Jack was finishing up his degree at Harvard,
his father,
Joseph Kennedy,
Sr,
was dealing with the very real possibility that the United States would join in
World War II even though he was living in London at the time.
Joseph Kennedy made it very clear that he was an isolationist,
which meant that he did not want Americans to join the war.
And in 1940 he made a comment in the press that he believed that he could
negotiate a peace treaty without off Hitler because of the statements.
People assumes that he was a Nazi sympathizer and he was forced to step down as
the ambassador Jack and his older brother Joe Jr both wanted to join the navy
after the United States officially entered World War Two in 1941 when Jack went
through the medical examination,
he was rejected because of his past back injury.
His father,
however,
paid off the army officials and they let him pass through.
Joe Junior went on to become a pilot in Europe.
Well,
Jack worked as the commander of a torpedo,
but in the South Pacific called PD one oh nine his back was in near constant
pain,
but he always suffered in silence,
swimming and sailing.
Every summer it paid off for Jack and a huge way because during the war,
PT 109 was attacked by the Japanese and it began to sink.
He spent three hours swimming around the rackage,
making sure that he had accounted for all of the survivors.
One of the men,
Patrick McMahon,
was badly burned all over his body and he could hardly move.
Kennedy was the strongest swimmer of the group.
So yeah,
to tow Patrick McMahon by pulling a string from his life jacket with his teeth,
he let his men as they swam three miles to a nearby island to safety and they
were rescued.
A week later when Jack returned home,
he weighed any 120 pounds and he was in excruciating pain cans,
wear a back brace and walk with a cane.
For several months he was awarded the Navy and Marine Corps metal for a service.
The entire family celebrated his bravery by throwing him a party.
Jack's older brother Joe Jr came home for the party,
but he felt a deep sense of shame because he never did anything to prove that he
was a war hero and it just happens to be like his younger brother Joe.
He accepted an extremely dangerous mission to carry heat sensitive explosives
and a plane boss before he could complete the mission,
the plane exploded in midair.
Joseph Kennedy Jr died at just 29 years old.
Jack Kennedy never wanted to be presidents of the United States.
He was very much a free spirit and he wasn't suited for politics.
He always that he wants it to be a writer who sailed around the world,
but now that Joe Jr was gone,
his father turned to Jack to fulfill all of his hopes and dreams even though he
didn't have very much experience in politics.
His father used as money and connections to propel JFK of case Korea supported
by their father,
has siblings pitched in by spending a lot of their time running Jack's campaign
as their full time job through his late twenties and early thirties he quickly
moved up the House of Representatives and then the Senate.
In 1953 John Kennedy married Jacqueline Bouvier.
She was a young social license,
a riser at the Washington time.
Harold,
just the like Jack.
She had also been groomed by how wealthy east coast family to be the perfect
first lady.
She could speak French,
Italian and Spanish fluently,
which ages later on in international diplomacy.
Soon after Marian Jacqueline JFK wrote his second book called profiles of
courage,
which won him the Pulitzer Prize.
In 1960 JFK became the Democratic nominee for the presidency when he was just 43
years old.
The public love to Jack Kennedy because he seems like any other normal guy.
He spoke with a Boston accents and he wasn't afraid to visit the factories and
shake the hands of the average American even though he came from a wealthy
family,
people knew that the Kennedys was self made and sold,
that he was very down to earth.
Young voters of the 1960s they were eager for change and he represented the
ideal American.
When he moved to the White House in 1961 jack placed his younger brother Bobby
as the new attorney general.
Even though he was only 35 years old,
the media was obsessed with the Kennedys.
Jackie would appear in magazines showing off our interior design skills at the
White House and it's a French fashion was always front page news.
Well,
they didn't know is the behind the scenes.
She was his rock.
She would help him by translating foreign books and documents all through the
night while also giving them a place to call home outside of work.
He loved spending time with his two children.
John Jr and Karen and Fred said that the oval office was always filled with the
kids' toys and the first thing he did every morning was watched cartoons and eat
cereal with them.
Despite having such a beautiful young family,
JFK was known for having not so secret affairs.
Raymond speculated that he was dating the buxom movie star,
Marilyn Monro and and phone records prove that she frequently called the White
House,
but for all of this secret fas,
Jackie never strayed from a loyalty she knew about his infidelity and considered
getting a divorce,
but chose to stay together for the sake of Jack's political career.
In later interviews,
Jackie said that Jack never stopped appreciating the fact that they were lucky
enough to live in the White House.
She described it as constantly feeling like a kid on Christmas because they were
always gushing over the history that surrounded them.
They never took a moment for granted.
The Kennedys,
youthful enthusiasm is often credited for pushing America through the space
race,
and Jeff k helped to bring America to the noon.
John gave the impression that he genuinely enjoyed his job as presidents.
He was known for smiling in the middle of a question from a journalist because
it already thought of what he come back.
He treated his press conferences almost like they were an audience for jokes
that he was writing in his spare time.
One day he was holding a piece of paper as if it was about to say something
incredibly serious to the crowd.
He then looked up and said
in space,
uh,
took off at 10 oh eight.
He reports that everything is perfect and working well.
He smiles in the room,
burst out in laughter
even though he was always smiling for the press.
John F.
Kennedy was an expert at hiding his pain.
He has been credited for saving the United States from the Cuban missile crisis
and preventing nuclear war during the Eisenhower Administration.
The CIA was planning to invade Cuba to bring down the communist leader Fidel
Castro.
When JFK was sworn into office in January of 1961 he was briefed on the plan
that was already underway.
This was the famous mission known as the Bay of Pigs,
and unfortunately it was not a failure.
After this,
Fidel Castro,
Captain American soldiers and threads in the United States with a nuclear bombs.
After a series of negotiations,
Kennedy agreed to send $53 million in baby food and medication to Cuba in
exchange for the lives of the American prisoners.
By notice 60 to the threats of nuclear war.
It's subsided and a collection of interviews called the Jackie Kennedy tapes.
We learned that it was terrifying for the young couple to and to office and
immediately have such a huge burden on their shoulders during the Cuban missile
crisis.
JFK was so upset about the possibility of nuclear war that he hardly slept and
one day simply bled into the next.
She also said that they had a conversation about what to do in the case of an
attack.
Jacqueline was more than willing to die with Jack.
She said that if there was not enough time to get to the bunker,
she would stand beside him on the White House lawn to watch the world.
And Jack Kennedy truly did care for the American people and he loved them even
if he didn't know them personally.
His wife,
Jackie,
said that he would often come home sobbing whenever he had any tragic news of
Americans dying.
You had first hand experience serving in World War II,
so the last thing he wanted was for the United States to get involved in the
Vietnam War.
The media accused him of being soft on communism,
but he was firm on his decision.
If he was still alive to complete a second time,
there is a very real possibility that the 58,220 Americans who died in Vietnam
would have never met that fate bus.
As we all know,
Lyndon B Johnson declared war on Vietnam in 1964
yeah.
On November the 22nd 1963 John F.
Kennedy and his presidential motorcade was driving through the streets of
Dallas,
Texas.
Jack was waving to the crowd and sickening next to his wife Jackie in the back
of the 1961 Lincoln continental,
the governor of Texas,
John Connolly and his wife were sitting in front of them just as they were
passing the Texas school book depository.
At least three shots were fired.
Jack was hit in the neck and the next was the fatal head shot.
At least one of the bullets I'll say had cannoli,
John F.
Kennedy.
He was pronounced dead and vice president Lyndon B Johnson assumed the role of
president of the United States,
the entire country.
It was stunned.
Everyone who was alive back then remembers exactly where they were when Jack
Kennedy was killed and the entire nation.
More at that president's a man named Abraham is approved.
It was in the crowd during the attack and he filmed the parade with his eight
millimeter camera.
He not the only one filming that day,
but he captured the clearest picture of what actually happens.
Once an engine,
bea Johnson became the new president's.
He ordered an investigation known as the Warren Commission to examine the facts
of the shooting,
including a frame by frame analysis of the Zapruder film.
The head of the CIA,
Allen duals,
was one of the men on the committee and many believe that his influence
completely manipulated the results of the investigation.
The Warren Commission came to the conclusion that Lee Harvey Oswald worked
alone.
He was already under investigation for collaborating with the Soviet Union and
for being a potential terrorist.
He also worked at the Texas school book depository,
which is where he had set up his gun before he could be questioned in court.
Oswald was killed two days later by a man named Jack Ruby.
The incident was broadcast on live TV.
All of this seems to convenience and plenty of people believe that there was a
much larger conspiracy at hands.
Now,
there are a lot of theories out there about who was behind JFK assassination,
so keep in mind that we'll never have enough time to go over all of them in this
video.
One of the many reasons why people find the Warren Commission so hard to believe
is the fact that only three shell casings were found that were fought by Lee
Harvey Oswald.
Two out of three bullets were shattered upon impact and even tiny fragments
behind.
How about the is one bullet.
There's supposedly traveled through both John F.
Kennedy and governor Connally's bodies and yet somehow it remained completely
intact.
This idea is called the magic bullet theory and it's honestly really hard to
believe.
Many people believe that there were more than just three shots fired and that
was a second gunman.
They believe this third,
but it was planted in the co off towards by the CIA.
If there was more than one shooter,
there is the very real possibility that multiple people were behind plotting his
death and the CIA wants us to believe that it was just one crazy American hating
terrorist.
One of the only ways to prove that the where are the shots,
five would be if we saw the proof on video.
There was supposedly a different angle films of the shooting by a man called
Orville Nix,
which is called the grassy knoll footage.
He sold one copy to the local press for $5,000 and he gave the second copy to
the FBI.
In this film,
there is supposedly evidence that there was a second shooter hiding behind the
bushes in a grassy knoll.
However,
the government sees the footage and Nick's claims that when he was given it
back,
there were sections of the tape that had been removed.
Orville Nix,
his granddaughter Gail Nix,
Jackson sued the u s government for $10 million or getting her family's original
film back.
This they claim to no longer have it in 2017 the CIA declassified thousands of
records about the JFK assassination that had never been seen by the public.
While it gives more insights into the case,
it does little to fuel the fire of any particular conspiracy theory.
We may never know the whole story of what happens during JFK assassination and
if the truth he wants to cover up,
we have no control over what's been done in the past.
If they could see what happened to his legacy,
surely Jack would want us to remember this.
He lived every day like it was his last,
and when asked if he has any regrets,
Sione said,
I wish I had more good times.
We'll leave you today with the words of Jacqueline Kennedy.
Jack was young and loved.
You know everything.
Jack was the most unselfconscious person I'd ever seen.
He could naturally be attractive in a crowd,
in a room.
It was like having so many things in common with the many sides of view.
Everyone found a part of themselves in Jack.
So I already have you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up.
11 don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several times per week,
so hit that subscribe button so you find out about all of those.
Also,
if you live with something else to watch right now,
why not click on one of the videos from the archives that are on the screen
right now?
And as always,
thank you for watching.